il était tard mais marcel voulait
rentrer chez lui alors il a pris le
volant ni marcel était fatigué il
n'arrivait pas à se concentrer et c'est
là qu'il a percuté un enfant qui
traversait la rue l'enfant est décédé
est ce que marcel a fait quelque chose
de mal
quoi qu'il en soit si l'on en croit
l'article l 232 1 en france marcel
serait jugé pour homicide involontaire
ce qui correspond à cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et 75 mille euros
damende ok mais la même nuit
augustin lui aussi était fatigué pire
encore augustin avait beaucoup bu
pendant sa soirée si bien que son taux
d'alcoolémie était largement au-delà de
la limite légale pour un conducteur
augustin était bien moins concentrés que
marcel encore si l'enfant avait traversé
la rue devant lui augustin non plus ne
se serait pas arrêté
oui mais voilà augustin est passée par
là même intersection que marcel les il y
est passé trente secondes avant marcelle
lorsqu augustin est passé l'enfant
n'avait pas encore traversé la rue
augustin n'a donc pas causé d'accident
ne sera pas poursuivi pour homicide
involontaire
il ne fera pas cinq ans de prison et il
ne paiera pas 75000 euros d'amendé
si je vous raconte tout ça ce n'est pas
pour que vous soyez attristé par le sort
de marcel vous frustré par la chance
d'augustin d'entités vers laquelle
j'aimerais que vous tourniez votre
attention
en tout cas pour le moment c'est en fait
notre système de justice
ce système ne punit pas les prises de
décision il punit les résultats des
prises de décision or il est largement
possible qu'une bonne décision conduise
à un mauvais résultat est qu'une
mauvaise décision conduise un bon
résultat ceux qui comprennent le mieux
ce paradoxe apparent sont peut-être les
joueurs de poker et peut-être en
particulier la joueuse de poker annie
duke hauteur du merveilleux livre
thinking in bête
ce livre est vraiment un bijou il est
certainement dans mon top 3 des
meilleurs livres de tous les temps si
vous voulez apprendre le bail à nice mme
pragmatique c'est le livre que je
recommande sans hésiter en particulier
dans ce livre annie duke explique que le
problème de nos systèmes de justice
c'est ce qu'elle a appelé le biais de
résultats qu annie duke illustre à
merveille dans son livre avec énormément
d'exemples qui vont du sport à la
politique en passant par les décisions
d'entreprise le journalisme est bien sûr
le poker le biais du résultat c'est
juger une décision à partir uniquement
du résultat de la décision
or ça c'est malheureusement ce qu'on
fait tout le temps quand une équipe de
football gagne un match sur un coup du
sort les notes des joueurs sont tout à
coup meilleurs comme si les joueurs
avaient bien joué parce qu'ils avaient
gagné le match quand benoît hamon a
obtenu des scores au premier tour
historiquement faible pour le parti
socialiste
on a été tenté de dire qu'il avait fait
une mauvaise campagne voir qu'il s'est
planté dans son choix d'idées à défendre
on a tendance à considérer que son échec
implique la faiblesse de sa stratégie
politique
et quand une start-up un artiste ou un
youtuber connaît le
succès il est tentant de penser que la
cause du succès réside dans la décision
ou les performances de cette start up de
cet artiste ou de ceux youtuber on a
tendance à penser que le succès prouve
le mérite
sauf que ça en pratique c'est une très
mauvaise façon de penser dans son livre
un idiot qui explique en effet que la
principale différence entre les joueurs
de poker amateurs et les joueurs
professionnels c'est à quel point ces
joueurs font un effort pour analyser
davantage les prises de décisions que
les résultats oui car ayant été joueur
très amateur moi même je sais très bien
que j'ai la fâcheuse tendance à donner
une importance démesurée à mes coups de
chance et au fameux bad beat
après un tournoi je vais me vantais des
mains improbable que j'ai gagné et je
vais me plaindre des coûts que j'aurais
dû gagner et que j'ai perdu c'est bien
sûr ses coûts qui sont les plus
spectaculaires les plus marquants et qui
attire le plus l'attention de mes
interlocuteurs
c'est via ses coups que je vais me
valorisé socialement mais parler de ces
événements littéralement extraordinaire
c'est aussi et surtout donner une
importance démesurée aux résultats et
surtout c'est beaucoup trop négligé la
réflexion sur le processus de prise de
décision c'est nous regarde et que le
hasard plutôt que se concentrer sur
notre véritable champ d'action et d'
influence de façon intrigante annie duke
raconte que les joueurs de poker déteste
ce genre de discussions ils
s'interdisent même de parler des coups
de chance et des bad beats
ou plutôt ils savent à quel point c'est
frustrant du coup il s'autorise une
fenêtre de temps de 24 heures pour se
plaindre ou se réjouir des coups de
chance de la veille cependant une fois
ce délai terminée il s'impose de ramener
constamment la discussion au processus
de prise de décisions au moment là de ma
partie world poker tour napt mode avec
une rail paire au flop et un bon kicker
avec encore trois personnes autour de la
table corrège dû le faire
ai-je bien fait de relancer quelles sont
les questions qu annie duke pose
régulièrement à des dirigeants
d'entreprise lors de séminaires qu'elle
leur donne l ai fait réfléchir et
débattre sur la prise de décision à ce
moment là mais surtout une fois le débat
sur la prise de décisions terminé à la
plus grande frustration de son auditoire
annie duke passe tout à coup à autre
chose mais at on bien fait de relancer
demande des dirigeants d'entreprise
qu'est ce qui s'est vraiment passé
pour la main en question annie duke
préfère ne pas répondre à ces questions
oui car explique-t-elle la tension du
preneurs de décisions au moment de la
prise de décision ne doit pas porter sur
le résultat qui aura effectivement lieu
ce qui doit l intéressé à ce moment
c'est comment prendre au mieux sa
décision sachant l'incertitude qu'il
doit avoir sur le résultat de la
décision
il faut donc prendre une décision malgré
l'incertitude du résultat il faut penser
non pas en termes de certitudes sur ce
qu'on sait déjà mais en termes de
crédence sur ce qu'on ne sait pas il
faut penser en termes de paris or
explique annie duke si je vous dis le
résultat de la main de poker vous
risquez de m'adjuger la qualité de votre
pari vous risquez de confondre la
qualité du résultat avec la qualité du
paris sauf qu'à cause de notre
incertitudes au moment du paris ce bon
pari peut être perdant alors qu'un
mauvais pari peut finir par être gagnant
or si maintenant je vous dis que le pari
est perdant vous risquez fort de
considérer consciemment ou non que le
pari était nécessairement mauvais vous
tomberiez alors dans le biais du
résultat bien sûr ça ne veut pas dire
qu'un résultat doit être ignorée c'est
une information qui reste utile à
prendre en considération pour les
décisions futures
cependant il faut prêter attention à ne
pas donner une importance démesurée aux
résultats sachant l'incertitude adéquate
à avoir au moment du paris ce résultat
aurait souvent largement pu être autre
et c'est pour éviter le biais du
résultat cani dieu que juge judicieux de
ne même pas mentionné ce résultat et
elle n'est pas la seule
annie duke raconte ainsi qu'à la suite
d'une victoire phil ivey l'un des
meilleurs joueurs de poker au monde
aimait détaillé méticuleusement le
déroulement des mains importante de la
partie qu'il avait gagné et ne sais
c'est de demander l'avis des autres sur
son processus de prise de décision ok
donc là je as 10 au pré flop
j'ai misé 3 fois à big blind et intel a
doublé la mise
il venait de perdre gros et je mettais
30% sur le fait qu'il soit en tilt il me
restait alors seulement 12 big bang dans
mon tapis
est ce que tu penses que à ce moment là
j'ai bien fait de faire tapis avec as 10
fille la vie et est ainsi persuadé que
c'est paris dans ses mains importante
était largement améliorable quand bien
même il avait gagné ses mains il voulait
réfléchir à comment mieux parier
et surtout ne présuppose et pas qu'il
avait bien parier simplement parce qu'il
avait gagné c'est paris juste après sa
victoire
son attention ne portait déjà plus sur
sa victoire elle portait sur son
processus de prise de décision dans les
mains qu'il venait de jouer et sur
comment améliorer ses paris qu'il
faisait de façon fascinante notamment
dans l'optique hashtag de bâton mieux
annie duke explique que cet état
d'esprit des joueurs de poker
professionnels forment alors un
environnement social qui pousse
constamment ses joueurs de poker a
ignoré les résultats pour se concentrer
uniquement sur la prise de décision
c'est cet environnement social qui
permet aux joueurs de progresser c'est
le fait qu'au quotidien
les joueurs de poker se désintéresse pas
mal des résultats des partis et n'ont
absolument aucun intérêt pour les coûts
de chance et de malchance qui fait que
ses joueurs s'améliorent et finiront par
gagner plus souvent contre des amateurs
que l' inverse
malgré les coups de chance et de
malchance j'insiste particulièrement sur
ça car c'est vraiment la raison d'être
du hashtag des bâtons mieux
l'environnement social avec lequel on
interagit quotidiennement et surtout ce
que cet environnement social valorise et
ne valorise pas à une influence énorme
sur nos propres façon de réfléchir un
environnement qui normalise le bullshit
créera des individus qui prennent
l'habitude de bullshit et un
environnement qui favorise la moquerie
et le sarcasme produira des hommes et
des femmes prêts à moquer
sarcastiquement tout ce qui les entoure
son faire attention aux subtilités des
arguments opposés et un environnement
qui valorise l'indignation amènera tous
ceux qui fréquentent cet environnement a
constamment s'indigner et à peut-être ne
pas faire suffisamment l'effort de
réfléchir à comment améliorer
efficacement la situation mais l inverse
un environnement qui favorise
l'honnêteté intellectuelle habituera ses
membres à questionner leurs croyances et
à vouloir progresser dans leur
compréhension du monde
un environnement qui encourage la
bienveillance créera des réflexes de
politesse et de bienveillance chez ces
individus qui finiront peut-être par
être gentil sans s'en rendre compte
enfin un environnement qui attire
constamment l'attention de tous sur les
processus de prise de décision aidera
tous à éviter le biais du résultat pour
mieux réfléchir a que faire sachant en
particulier l'incertitude sur le
résultat au moment de la prise de
décision oui car pour comprendre la
cause profonde du bien du résultat il
faut beaucoup plus valoriser un mot en
particulier le mot incertitude
raisonnons avec incertitude embrassons
l'incertitude car à bien y réfléchir
cette incertitude est vraiment partout
bien sûr dans le poker mais aussi au
moment d'entamer une campagne électorale
un projet entrepreneurial ou un projet
de recherche
en fait quand on commence un projet de
recherche il vaut mieux ne pas trop
savoir ce qu'on va obtenir c'est tout le
principe de faire de la recherche et du
coup au moment de choisir un projet de
recherche en particulier il faut bien
admettre qu'on est dans un état
d'incertitude et il nous faut absolument
inclure cette incertitude pour choisir
le projet entamé et surtout il ne faut
pas considérer que l'absence de résultat
est une preuve d'un mauvais choix de
projets de recherche
de façon générale il est crucial de se
souvenir qu'au moment de nos prises de
décision les résultats de ces décisions
étaient inconnues pour optimiser la
prise de décision en présence d'
incertitudes
il nous faut alors imaginez les
résultats probables impliqué par la
prise de décision comme l'a d'ailleurs
fait dans la vidéo précédente
il nous faut parier sur l'avenir c'est
pour ça que plutôt que de parler de
prise de décision qui peut laisser
entendre qu'on sait ce qu'on fait il est
peut-être préférable de parler de paris
pour insister sur l'incertitude qui
règne au moment de la prise de décision
nous l'expression d'un king bed
introduite par annie duke
je pense que c'est vraiment quelque
chose de fondamental il me semble y
avoir énormément à gagner à voir chaque
prise de décision comme un pari un pari
qui n'est pas complètement aveugle mais
un pari néanmoins plein d'incertitudes
penser en termes de paris et s'habituer
à parier c'est en fait l'un des piliers
du paysagisme et pour développer cette
bonne pratique épistémique je vous
invite notamment à tester cette nouvelle
application développée par lui faut
qu'on doctorant à le pfl qui vous
propose de répondre à des qcm bayésiens
avec une notation pro honnêteté
appliquons cela au cas de marcel et
augustin marcel at-il vraiment mal fait
de prendre la voiture sachant qu'il
était fatigué
honnêtement qui de nous n'a jamais pris
le volant en étant fatigué mais surtout
qui de nous a jugé qu'il s'agissait
alors d'une mauvaise décision nous sur
les réponses à ces questions sont
incroyablement contextuel ça dépend
d'eux à quel point on est fatigué quelle
est la longueur du trajet et ainsi de
suite
mais force est de constater que la
plupart d'entre nous n'a surtout jamais
eu la malchance cahul marcel
al'inverse la décision d'augustin semble
bien plus mauvaise que celle de marcel
cette décision est bien plus discutable
car même si la probabilité de ne causer
aucun accident demeurent assez grande
la probabilité de causer un accident
mortel devient alors non négligeable or
une probabilité faible mais non
négligeable de causer une catastrophe
semble largement justifié le fait que
parier dessus est une mauvaise décision
bref en termes de paris il n'y a pas
photo le paris de marcel est beaucoup
plus raisonnable que celui d'auguste ans
même si en termes de résultats marcel a
causé une catastrophe et augustin pas
ceci dit malheureusement notre système
judiciaire ne juge pas les paris il juge
les résultats
selon annie duke il s'agit là d'un
billet présent dans nos sociétés de
façon assez générale nous pensons
beaucoup trop en termes de résultats et
ça nous conduit à beaucoup trop de
mauvaises décisions
pire encore on a même tendance notamment
en sciences a refusé de penser en termes
de paris et a par exemple moquer ceux
qui mettent des probabilités sur des
événements futurs
mais alors inéluctablement dans des
problèmes complexes
on sera à vous et à préférer l'excès de
confiance et à prendre de mauvaises
décisions
pire encore à cause du biais du résultat
on risque fort de ne jamais progresser
et donc de persister à prendre des
mauvaises décisions avant d'en revenir
aux questions de la vidéo précédente
j'en profite pour parler à nouveau de
l'application bel homme point web point
ap avec laquelle non seulement vous
pouvez répondre à un questionnaire
j'ai préparé justement un questionnaire
d'alésiens juste pour vous sur le baiser
nisme vous invite à essayer de le tester
et de surtout essayer de maximiser
l'expérience de votre score
à ce jeu en essayant notamment de
décrire adéquatement l'étendue de votre
ignorance et sachez également qu'en
créant un compte sur v 1.1 10.1 ap vous
pouvez aussi créer vos propres qcm
bayésiens et du coup puiser vos propres
amis de manière bayésienne
la dernière fois on avait parlé d'
offrir un cadeau de noël optimale et
florent thomas s'est fait la remarque
que lorsqu'on fait les calculs il vient
ça prend beaucoup de temps et d'énergie
en fait il ya un coût associé aux
calculs et on peut en plus finir par ne
rien faire peut-être peut-être de ne pas
réaliser par les calculs à effectuer
dans ce cas on serait pas rationnel au
sens instrumentales comme l'expliquent
hygiène mentale dans cette vidéo peut
être encore apparaître sais pas s'il ya
déjà parus en fait ce qui est plus
adéquat de faire c'est d'anticiper au
moment d'un premier calcul parisien dit
qu est du coup très approximatif le coup
de calcul le paysan qui va venir se
demander si ces coûts de calcul en terme
de temps et d'énergie
est ce que ces coups de calcul sont
justifiées ce qu'ils vont nous permettre
vraiment de réduire suffisamment notre
incertitudes que mon avec notre
intuition sans réfléchir et de même
façon acquérir de l'information à kayar
davantage d'informations pour réduire
cette incertitude a également un coût et
il faut prendre en compte ce coup
lorsqu'on se met à décider de ace combat
chercher à réduire notre incertitudes et
je reparlerai de tout ça notamment quand
on abordera le principe de précaution de
manière bayésienne raid comme bush la
questionne le fait de maximiser
l'espérance et se demande par exemple
est ce qu'on boit pas prendre en compte
la variance bien pour bien apprendre à
cette question il faut bien réfléchir à
quel est le nombre dont on prend
l'espérance truc qui peut arriver et qui
me semble arriver à ces semences et
qu'on a tendance à négliger la réflexion
sur quel est le score dont on prend
l'espérance en particulier si on est
rationnel ce score peut-être assez
différent de ce qu'on voudrait mettre
intuitivement comscore typiquement quand
il est question d'argent alors
l'espérance de l'argent n'était en fait
pas nécessairement ce qu'on veut
maximiser et pour plus de détails je
vous renvoie vers la vidéo que j'ai fait
dans le ciel sur démocratie ou
l'excellente vidéo de sciences étonnante
surtout ses problèmes notamment nous ce
qu'on appelle la conca éviter de
fonction d'utilité vis-à-vis
de l'argent qui permet de refléter la
version risque tout ce qui est notamment
variance démission d'alain être une
certaine manière encodées dans la forme
de la fonction utilisée c'est à dire la
manière de calculer les scores à partir
de l'argent que l'on a pour prendre en
compte cela l'argent ne doit pas être
considérée comme le score à maximiser et
de la même façon dans le cadre de
l'utilitarisme on a tendance à penser
qu'il faut maximiser l'espérance d'une
métrique du bonheur de différentes
personnes voire la somme des bonheurs de
différentes personnes où la moyenne est
utile pas que c'est faux mais si on fait
ça eh bien il ya un fort risque qu'on
pense qu'en fait mal la réflexion sur le
score à maximiser parce que ce choix du
score doit être en fait intimement lié
avec les notions de hasard et de
probabilités et d'incertitudes
or si on dit juste le bonheur a priori
le bonheur intrasèque on a tendance à
mesurer c'est en tout cas intuitivement
indépendant de ces notions
d'incertitudes qui fait que ça
correspond pas nécessairement tout à
fait à ce qu'on obtiendrait si on
appliquait le cadre de vos no man u
morgenstern
c'est aussi pour ça que j'ai tendance à
parler plutôt de ce corps qu de fonction
d'utilité
non pas parce que la notion de fonction
d'utilité me semble erronée mais parce
que elle a tendance à suggérer qu'on va
se placer dans un cadre utilitariste
alors qu'on peut largement être
conséquent ces listes bayésiens et se
moquer complètement de du bonheur des
gens on peut même être conséquents
sélestadiens est complètement neutres
vis-à-vis du bonheur des gens qui est un
petit peu bizarre quand même
mais a priori c'est tout à fait possible
notamment en incluant dans le calcul du
score des choses comme par exemple la
relation à ou mensonge la relation à la
loyauté ou d'autres notions comme ceux
ci qui sont généralement négligée
complètement par l'utilitarisme je suis
pas en train de dire que l'une des
théories à plus vrai que l'autre ce que
j'essaie de dire surtout c'est que le
cadre de la vidéo précédente à savoir le
conséquentialiste bayésiens permet en
fait d'avoir une expressivité qui est
beaucoup beaucoup plus grande que le
cadre utilitariste classique
elle espère qu'ils avaient mais cette
vidéo qu un petit peu cette nuit
parti sur le bike and is no pragmatique
on y reviendra
mais pour les prochaines vidéos
j'aimerais parler à nouveau de trucs un
peu plus théorie un peu plus
joli devenir un peu plus fondamentaux
notamment le but d'andy doit venir je
suis disposé à la question est ce que le
hasard n'existe contre ou si vous avez
vu cette vidéo pour céréales qu'elle a
commenté elle a partagé pense à vous
abonner pompiers épisode martiaux tipper
power dont j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois il ya notamment un groupe
de recherche à l'université de moncton
au canada qui a en 2007 a publié un
programme qui pour la première fois
était capable de battre des joueurs
professionnels de poker pour un de ses
plaies polaris
alors ce programme il était très très
fort il battait des pros mais il n'était
pas mathématiquement imbattable il était
juste très fort comme les programmes qui
joue aux échecs
aujourd'hui et début 2015 cette même
équipe a poussé le bouchon beaucoup plus
loin puisque cette fois ils ont résolu
le jeu de poker dans cette variante
heads up limite c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
publié un nouveau programme qui
s'appelle s'est fait lui et qui lui est
mathématiquement imbattable et sans
doute à ce plus pertinent de considérer
ainsi les situations façon comparative
comme meilleur ou pire qu'une autre et
non pas de bonnes ou mauvaises
absolument en somme le l'idée
fondamentale derrière toute approche
conséquentialiste est assez simple il y
à des situations du monde meilleurs que
d'autres
objectivement préférable à d'autres et
donc tu dois faire ce qui contribue à
réaliser de telles situations plutôt que
les eaux